la barrière encore
donc on peut finalement comme ça si tu
veux
mais non mais c'est la première qui
tombe ah j'ai posé un pied
Jennifer vous connaissez
incroyable
c'est ça moi je vais avoir 72 ans il y a
un moment où il faut pas se remplir le
cerveau avec des conneries trop massifs
inconfortable alors vous êtes pas à
l'aise mais tellement pas et en plus je
la chantais pas comme ça je voulais pas
la chanter comme ça mais vous avez 14
ans tout juste vous êtes un bébé
de ne pas avoir donné ce que je pouvais
donner les cinq personnes les plus
riches les ce sont les mêmes personnes
qui appauvrissent la France et elles
appauvrissent l'Afrique je vais vous
donner l'exemple rien que de Bolloré le
Cameroun l'exemple de pouyanais de chez
Total qui est en train de faire un
projet Ouganda le type refuse de taxer
les supports vous voulez
spectateurs
[Musique]
du groupe Bolloré
tu viens foutrichienne mais j'ai aucun
problème
et j'ai aucun problème
est-ce que tu es en train de dire que
j'ai pas le droit de dire publiquement
que Bolloré il a un procès avec 154
cet extra exquis
[Applaudissements]
à parler comme une meuf de la street
ça donne quoi du coup
il va pas oui elle m'a dit le souci va
pas wesh frère il y a un problème ça va
je le fais bien arrête de prendre la
tête là
et elle a dit il était un militant
engagé un patriote sincère et d'une
gentillesse sans égal aujourd'hui Kevin
cormillot nous a quitté mais plus
sincère condoléances à sa famille à ses
proches
tu fais du mal à voir
tu fais du mal à la France en disant et
tu fais tu sais quoi c'est les langues
il a fait ce tweet
quelqu'un qui est mort sans dit long sur
la psychologie des gens de la France
insoumise il a fait ce tweet monsieur
Alan Bruno je termine il retrouvera en
enfer ses idoles les Léon Gauthier les
pierres Bousquets et les autres
vaffenets et cesse fondateurs du FN un
jour vous m'avez appelé vous m'avez dit
tiens des propos communautariste
je te dis quoi moi je te dis quoi dans
les messages
se rend compte de l'embrouille
je te dis je te dis je sais même pas je
ne sais même pas de quoi tu parles et tu
es venu ici pour faire le malin
ça devrait même pas être à côté de ton
patron sur ta chaîne ça devrait même pas
écoute-moi bien moi je ne crache pas
dans la main qui mouille et toi tu
devrais pas cher
autant de responsabilités
[Applaudissements]
pas mal le roi en personne a pris la
parole à la télévision pour annoncer que
sa fille aînée la princesse Martin
Louise ne représentera plus la famille
royale en cause ces fiançailles et son
mariage à venir avec l'américain Durc
véreth qui se définit lui-même comme un
chaman un guide spirituel autoproclamé
très en vogue auprès des stars à
Hollywood comme Gwenn paltro ou Antonio
Banderas
[Applaudissements]
ça fait flipper les écoles
dans son dernier livre ce Durk vérès
explique accrochez-vous bien que le
cancer est un choix et sur son site
internet on peut acheter un médaillon à
200 dollars qui permettrait de se
protéger du covid Léa tu n'es pas une
danseuse mais ton sourire et
communicatif continue les efforts ça
veut dire quoi communicatif bah c'est
bien c'est pas bien ah oui c'est
communicatif c'est super bien ah ouais
excuse-moi moi je vais les prendre
j'aime trop
moi
en tout doux emplois créés un premier
CDI pour Nathalie Verlet 58 ans ancienne
caissière en CDD
quelques mois après on m'a appelé on se
savait pas du tout faire et on m'a
appelé le métier et maintenant bah moi
j'adore quoi et je trouve ça super et
d'avoir
à faire les peluches encore mieux
le mec
bonjour moi je vois votre sourire voilà
non mais c'est vrai c'est ça qui
m'intéresse parce qu'en fait je vois
plus tôt le stock que la vitrine c'est à
dire que je vois plutôt l'intérieur de
l'être que la alors je vous attends vous
qui nous regardez là gilbertville
mais non c'est pas ça c'est que vraiment
je suis plus branché sur l'intérieur des
gens et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
vraiment